for the last two decades madden NFL has
consistently ranked among the top video
games in America bringing in four
billion dollars for Electronic Arts one
man has helped fuel that success and
it's not John Madden this is the
database and this is where basically I
literally will make a change you can see
every player has every right neat Donnie
Moore Madden's ratings are his rankings
take NFL players from the field to the
game and with 32 NFL teams 74 players
per team plus 250 free agents and 50
legends that's 2668 players to whom
Donnie assigns a rating of up to a
hundred in 64 different categories like
strength speed and catching scores he
creates using data from game performance
team stats and his own nose I want the
game to look like an NFL game we don't
want to put something in where if you
give a guy a one-speed he's just easy
he's out there inching along exploiting
bad player ratings on EA's old NCAA
football games is how Donny got his job
at madden so I am this moon wow just
like those who feel like a you could
just span this the swim button at that
point I you know we could probably fine
tune this process a little better so
there's no accidental gameplay mistakes
that like literally make somebody way to
business unity today Donnie's ratings
have helped EA make Madden looks so good
the franchise has sold over 100 million
units touchdown but sometimes players
disagree I have a problem debt I feel
I've got better I know I've gotten
better they've been the same right now
so disrespect what are these numbers
from active on Twitter Donnie is willing
to take feedback from fans gamers
coaches and especially players about his
ratings there's a reason these guys are
obviously NFL players and other some
stars there's also a reason that they're
like you know going eighty percent
completion percentage and it's the
reason the Texans went 2-14 just fight
having JJ Watt who's 99 overall on their
teen there's this we're trying to
capture that right we can't be the pan
out lollipops with radiant I ratings to
every
every team and player not even to the
highest rated player in the game I can
just see this now right I'm going to
Denver and you know pig man will come in
and i'll be super honored I mean I've
never met the man and he's a great great
guy well Payton you know sorry this year
you're down to 86 dope our buddy I mean
you're 38 years old and you know I can't
not gonna be the guy to tell Peyton
Manning so while anybody else would be
focused on hanging out with Pro Bowl
quarterbacks and wide receivers Donnie
only cares about making madden 15 a
great video game